Making a Star Wars movie is a demanding and
pressure-filled task.
There are millions of people carefully watching
the film’s development, meaning it’s on
the director and screenwriters to craft a
compelling, entertaining story filled with
memorable characters.
They’re – justifiably – so concerned
about getting the larger picture down pat,
that sometimes they can’t catch the tiniest
error while overseeing the final cut.
Here are 10 Star Wars movie mistakes that
slipped through editing.
The Falcon’s Rader Dish – A New Hope
The design of the Millennium Falcon is extremely
iconic and well known across the globe, including
its radar dish.
Fans are so aware of that component that J.J.
Abrams made sure to update it for The Force
Awakens.
But before the Falcon became a part of cinematic
lore, the filmmakers weren’t too concerned
with its overall look.
When it’s first shown in the 1977 original,
the radar dish is nowhere to be seen, magically
appearing when the ship reaches space.
No explanation is provided, and with all the
alterations this movie has seen in the years
since, it’s surprising George Lucas never
fixed this.
Captain Antilles Returns from the Dead – A
New Hope
Darth Vader is firmly established as an intimidating
villain in his first few moments of screen
time, particularly when he chokes and kills
Captain Antilles with his bare hands.
When the Rebel captain is dead, Vader tosses
his body aside towards a wall.
Though Antilles is supposed to be dead, the
actor clearly raises his hands for protection
as he makes impact.
Conceivably, multiple takes of the scene were
done, but this was the one that made the finished
film.
Maybe there was no way around it.
It’s probably better for the actor to use
his hands quickly than get a face full of
wall.
Han’s Carbonite Pose – The Empire Strikes
Back
Han Solo being frozen in carbonite is one
of the most emotional moments in the entire
saga, and viewers were probably too caught
up in his wellbeing to notice that his hands
change positions before and after the process.
As Han is enters the chamber, his hands are
visibly in handcuffs, and they are never removed.
When his frozen body is shown for the first
time, the cuffs are no longer there and his
hands appear to be grasping something.
It is jarring to see, and it’s a mystery
that will most likely never be solved.
Perhaps the handcuffs are adverse to cold
temperatures?
C-3PO’s Breathing – The Empire Strikes
Back
Anthony Daniels was the perfect pick to play
protocol droid C-3PO, but even he couldn’t
truly master portraying the character in a
deactivated state.
When his constant worrying annoys Han and
Leia, C-3PO is switched off so the two can
have a talk in peace.
If you watch C-3PO closely, you’ll notice
that he’s moving in the background – an
indicator of Daniels’ breathing – instead
of being completely still.
It’s understandable that Daniels couldn’t
hold his breath for the entire time, but with
a massive budget, they could have built a
model of the droid to avoid any problems.
Luke the Ventriloquist – Return of the Jedi
Luke is apparently so skilled with the Force,
he can use it to speak without moving his
mouth.
As he looks to make a daring escape of Jabba’s
barge with Leia, Luke tells his sister, “Come
on” before the two swing off to safety.
Though audiences hear Mark Hamill deliver
the line, it’s obvious that the actor did
not actually say it while on set.
His lips do not move during this part, creating
a glaring audio error that’s never been
fixed.
Most likely, this was a result of dubbing
in post, but somebody should have told Hamill
to at least mouth the line so it looked natural
on screen.
Inverted Starship Controls – The Phantom
Menace
When young Anakin stays in a fighter cockpit
to stay safe from the fight, things don’t
go according to plan and he ends up in a space
battle with R2-D2.
Once the autopilot is overwritten, he plays
around with the controls to get a feel for
his new ride.
He tries to do a spin move, turning the steering
mechanism to the left.
But the vehicle spins to the right.
This is particularly egregious since right
before this sequence, Anakin turned the ship
left by moving the steering mechanism in that
direction.
One of the moves is incorrect, an unintended
question George Lucas never meant to pose.
Walking Through Doors – Attack of the Clones
The prequels pushed the boundaries of digital
filmmaking, and while the spectacle was impressive,
it wasn’t always seamless.
After landing on Geonosis, Anakin and Padme
enter the underground droid factory.
When the door opens, they have to duck to
get through.
While Natalie Portman is able to enter without
any issues, the taller Hayden Christensen
wasn’t so lucky.
Though he does lower himself, it wasn’t
far enough, and his head goes through the
digital door that was created in post.
A lot of work goes into adding CGI, but it
couldn’t have been too hard to slightly
alter this so it wasn’t so noticeable.
Obi-Wan’s Clean Clothes – Revenge of the
Sith
After a lightsaber duel on a volcanic planet,
one would expect that your outfit would suffer
some damage, especially in a physical confrontation
like Anakin vs. Obi-Wan.
Yet, when Kenobi comes back on board the ship
to leave Mustafar, his costume has little-to-no
indication of a titanic struggle, appearing
relatively clean.
Later on, when Obi-Wan discusses what to do
with the Skywalker twins with Yoda and Bail
Organa, his costume sports several dirt and
burn marks, which should have been present
earlier on.
Obi-Wan probably didn’t get burned on his
ship, so he must have suffered these on Mustafar.
Finn’s Disappearing Blaster – The Force
Awakens
When landing on Takodana, Han Solo gives Finn
a blaster for protection, which he carries
with him at all times.
He’s shown holding the blaster when Maz
Kanata gives him Luke’s old lightsaber to
give to Rey, but when the First Order bombs
Maz’s castle, Finn remarks that he needs
a weapon to defend himself, before learning
that the lightsaber is a weapon.
Since the blaster was on Finn at all times,
it’s odd that it’s all of a sudden missing
when he needs it the most, with no explanation
provided for why it’s gone.
Boarding the Falcon’s Ramp – The Force
Awakens
During their hectic escape from Jakku, Rey,
Finn and BB-8 are left with no choice but
to give the Millennium Falcon a shot and see
if it will fly.
When the trio approaches the ship, the come
to the ramp from the right side of it.
Yet, when the characters are shown boarding
the Falcon, they’re coming from the left
side of the ramp.
Given that they were in a life-or-death situation,
it seems odd they would run all the way around
to get on their only option available.
Chalk this one up to the dangers of splicing
multiple takes.
Those are our picks for Star Wars movie mistakes
that made it through editing.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you notice every time you journey
to a galaxy far, far away?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!